hello everyone uh we've seen a lot of
modern games these past few days with
the world
rapid and blitz championship and the
carlson nakamura speed chess
championship so
it would be refreshing to see a nice
mikaltel game uh this game was a
suggestion from a subscriber and it's a
great game for two reasons uh one
because it really is a great game and
two because it was played in the final
round of the 1957 ussr
championship in moscow uh before the
final round tal was tied in first place
with dolozhir and david bronstein
all three of them with 13 points and
there's a lot on the line here
uh whoever wins probably will take the
ussr
championship so fortunately for tal he
has the white pieces
uh but you know like i said it's it's an
amazing tournament
20 22 amazing players uh 22 monsters
uh would be more precise as uh there was
uh mikhail tal david brunson and paul
karas
uh tigran petrossian boris pasque victor
korchner
a lot of amazing players so you know
winning a tournament like this
is something to really you know put in
your resume
uh so tal has the white pieces and he
opens up with c4 the english opening
we have knight to f6 knight to c3 g6
e4 by tal d6 d4
and bishop to g7 now column of uh sorry
tolus transposes into the king's indian
defense
we have f3 tagos for the semis variation
e5
knight g2 e2 knight bd7 bishop to g5
c6 queen to d2 uh we have castles
d5 and c5 and tal closed at the center
here so now he can
expand on the queen on the king side and
attack
g4 by tal we have a6
stopping any maybe future ideas of
knight b5 also
preparing b5 uh black will definitely
want to start expanding on the queen
side as well
uh knight to g3 by tal rook to e8 and
now
h4 preparing h5 of course queen to a5
and now bishop to h6 tal wants to
exchange the dark square bishop
knight to f8 we have h5 queen to c7 and
the bishop to d3
and already you can see that tao's
position is much better here he already
uh started his attack and uh black
really doesn't uh get anything in return
here tull didn't even have to
you know spoil his position or sacrifice
a single pawn to get
to get anything out of the position
already he started his
attack uh b5 by uh alexander tolus
uh tal castle's queen side and b
captures on c4
and here probably capturing the pawn on
c4 is the best
thing to do but tell goes bishop to b1
this is
how tal plays chess he wants his bishop
to be on this diagonal
uh bishop to h8 we have rook d
to g1 now and rook to b8 and here tal
plays knights to f5
uh you can't really react to this if you
capture the knight with the g characters
on f5
this will ultimately lead to your doom
with g captures on f5 uh there's
now an open attack from the rook to your
king uh you have to block this the king
has nowhere to go
so let's say knight g6 h captures
f captures f captures and uh you don't
really have anything here after rook
captures
simply queen cap queen to g5 uh
the threat of course is the thread is
rook to g7 and after king to e7 now
bishop to g7 and you're losing a piece
you can't capture the bishop
the rook will capture and then black
loses the queen so something like king
to d8 and now rook captures an h8 and
it's uh completely winning for white so
after knight to f5
of course stolis completely ignores this
he plays knight 6 to d7
and here we have bishop to g5
h captures on g6 is perfectly fine for
white this is completely winning
but tal plays bishop to g5 and
he he he tries to set up a trap here for
black
what's the idea here bishop
g7 was played but what did thal want
with this bishop to g5 move
probably he wanted talish to play
something like f6 to go
after this bishop but then after knight
to h6 check
king to g7 uh and the bishop to e3
probably wanted to provoke g5
kind of to block all of tal's uh king
side pawns
but now actually bishop to g5 is winning
for white
f captures queen captures and after
knight to g6 simply
knight to f5 king moves you you you
check the king
king goes here and knight now h captures
on g6
knight f8 and let's say g captures an h7
with check
and black is destroyed here but uh those
doesn't go for this after bishop to g5
he plays bishop to g7
and here we have knight captures on g7
king captures and now bishop to h6 check
by tal
king to g8 and now f4
e captures on f4 queen captures on f4
and queen to d8 we have h captures on g6
knight captures on g6 with a tempo on
the queen and queen to h2
uh probably capturing the d6 pawn would
again
be perfectly fine and you know why not
grab such a nice central pawn
but i'll plays queen to h2 eyeing that
h7 pawn after the bishop moves
so knight d to e5 we have bishop to f4
now uh
attacking the the h7 pawn and knight
knight to f8 now defending the h7 pawn
uh queen to h6 we have knight e to g6
and now bishop to g5 attacking taller's
queen
and now f6 and finally tal managed to
provoke
f6 and uh it it's in this position that
you really have to find a very nice
stall move
uh sure you can move the bishop you can
move the bishop to h4
you'll still have a better position you
can move it to d2 you'll still have a
better position
but there is a very nice towel move in
the position and
if you want you know it's not a very
hard move uh but it's a tall move so
you know you'll feel proud if you play
the same move towel plate
feel free to pause the video and try to
try to find
tal's move so i hope
some of you have tried it for those of
you who managed to find tales move
congratulations
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show in this position tile
plate e5
and what's the idea of e5 well for once
you're waking up this sleeping bishop on
b2 now this bishop
becomes alive and it will be a very
dangerous piece uh if you capture the
bishop on g5 this doesn't really
work for black if you capture it then
comes the bishop captures on g6
and you can't capture it with the knight
if you capture with the knight then
queen captures on h7 the knight has to
protect h7
so after if you play h captures then
comes queen to h8
check king to f7 and now rook to h7
check
knight captures queen captures and after
king moves
uh rook to h1 actually and uh
it it does seem black has a lot of
pieces but if you look at them none of
them can really help out
with the defense after something like d
captures an e5 queen captures on g6
and there really is no stopping rook to
h8 uh
rook to b7 now d6 blocking
the king's escape to e7 and there's
really nothing
uh black can do against the rook to h8
checkmate
uh so after e5 rook captures on e5 was
played by tolus
and now comes bishop captures on g6
uh rook to b7 as
you've just seen you can't capture the
bishop uh and knights to e4 now again
with a very complicated position here
those played
f captures on g5 he captures the bishop
but now comes rook to f1
and what do you play here uh talish
played rook captures an e4
if you try something like knight
captures on g6 this simply doesn't work
knight to f6 check you have to run with
the king king to f7 and now comes
queen captures on h7 king f8 queen to g8
check king e7 and now rook to h7 and
this is checkmate
so after look to f1 total stride rook
captures an e4
okay he had to give up a rook bishop
captures on e4
and now rook to g7 but this doesn't
really have black that much style plays
rook to f6
now is preparing rook h1 to f1 doubling
up on the f file
bishop to g4 we have rook h2f1 now tile
doubles up on df file
uh knight to d7 attacking tells rook but
now simply us
a silent move actually is perfectly fine
uh towel plays rook
captures on d6 and black is completely
busted
uh here polish plays queen to e7 uh goes
for the bishop on e4 and how do you
defend the bishop
uh you don't defend the bishop tell
place rook captures on a6
and this is terrible for black you can't
capture the bishop if you capture the
bishop
then comes rook to a8 check and the
black is getting checkmated after he
gives up
all of his pieces as there is really no
way to block this check
so after rook to a6 king to a cheat uh
is preparing to meet rook 8 with rook g8
but tal doesn't allow anything like that
he plays bishop captures on h7
immediately
uh knights the b8 again if you capture
it then
rook to a8 comes with the same idea uh
so at
bishop captures on h7 knight the b8 was
played attacking the rook
but now comes bishop to f5
uh this comes with a discovered check
and uh
here tulsh played king to g8 and this
would be
a great opportunity for tal to blunder
the game if he played something like
bishop captures on g4 to
to grab a piece uh because he now those
would actually have a perpetual check
and it would be a draw after queen to e3
check
you have to move king d1 and now queen
d3 check king you want
now queen to g3 check uh you can't go to
e2 to get to a light square
because you lose the bishop with check
so after king d2 queen d3 now with
check also attacking the rook king has
to defend it again queen g3 and this is
a perpetual
uh it would be a draw but fortunately
volta
fortale after this uh move tao plays
bishop to e6
check the king has nowhere to go the
queen is uh
uh controlling this file the rook is
controlling this file so the bishop has
to be captured
uh bishop captures on e6 was played and
now rook captures on e6
and it was in this position that
alexander resigned the game
uh tal is up the exchange but that
really doesn't matter as
he does have a forced checkmate after
the queen moves uh
queen to h5 for example threatening rook
to d8 to check winning the queen
uh after you block this simply queen
checks uh king moves and now rook to h1
threatening rook to h8 to checkmate uh
after we play something like
anything there's really no defense
against this you have to play something
then you get to checkmated so after this
uh rook to e6 move uh alexander tulsh
resigned the game
uh mikhail tal won the 1957 ussr
championship
with 14 points out of 21. uh second
place
was actually uh won by paul carris who
won his
uh last game and the third place was
david bronstein
i think alexander tolsh here in the end
got fifth place
and uh this is the tournament where
rashid najmentino actually
defeated tal and in this tournament
mikhail tal
out of 21 games he only lost two games
he lost to uh izaki
and that famous game against rashid
nejmedinov
which you probably already seen on my
channel if you haven't do check it out
it's a it's pretty wild game
so yeah that's the game this is how
mikhail tal won the 1957 ussr
championship in moscow i do hope you
enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon